i'll be on thank you
members
apologies for absence
we have
we have received apologies for absence
from councillor david merrick council
elisa newport and councillor carol
weston
and councillor lorman
sorry sorry i can't hear her
and councillor oh and sorry we just now
received
apologies for councillor reeves
councillor mrs mason is
substituting for council lisa newport
and councillor constable is substituting
for councillor weston
we have no members attending is
councillor cheryl rowe and councillor
simon wooten
anyone else
thank you
members minutes of the
meeting held on the 26th of
october 2021 are they agreed members
agreed
thank you
item five to receive declarations of
interest
have we any oh i've got two
council williams
daniel because lefty can you pass the
mic
[Music]
thanks to my assistant
thank you chairman um yeah i have a
non-pecuniary interest in item number
six
being that i'm a member of the rochester
parish council and i'm also known to the
architect thank you very much thank you
that's refd
gain item six and what should parish
councillor i don't know the architect
thank you very much have we got any
other declarations of interest
no thank you members
item six is the um
to 72 west street rockford to consider
an application to demolish an existing
building and erect a part two and
three-story building comprising retail
restaurant units at ground floor floor
together with self-contained flats
above 29 flats to include cycle store
and car park
car parkings to the rear and specular in
access to west street i believe
mike strength is
good thank you mike thank you chairman
um
this application as we can see
on the screen is in rochford town centre
at the junction of union lane which
gives access to the hospital west street
which leads off the market square
bradley way to the south here mulberry
pub is a landmark in the sainsbury's
building here it's a prominent site in
the conservation area if we could look
at plan two please
before we look at the detailed plans
there's a very useful visual being
prepared 3d image gives us a context
here we see the adjoining restaurant
listed building onto west street
the crusty pipe
restaurant we have the more modern
sainsbury's building on the corner here
while we're in this image this is
particularly good to show the uh shop
front details to the two retail
restaurant units
you'll see they mirror the kind of
treatment architecturally that was given
to the sainsbury's building on this
prominent corner
the proposal as the description says is
to demolish the existing buildings on
the site which are former
showrooms and
vehicle garages indeed is used currently
by a company who service and repair
cars
and to construct a three-story building
which we see in a moment
that is three stories uh but has some
rooms um in in the roof
you'll see that the development from the
description comprises twelve one bedroom
flats sixteen two bedrooms and one three
bedroom flat 29 in in total
and with 21 car parking spaces including
one for the
impaired and as we said earlier it also
includes two commercial
units onto west street we can see plan
three please
this plan you'll see shows the building
before you tonight in the dark outline
here this is a street scene view taking
us from the flats through the entrance
to their car park in the back of the
sainsburys this is the sainsburys
building then we have union lane then we
have the subject building tonight then
the continuation of the
north side of west street frontage
and the lower
elevation you see the junction point
here
and the building's opposite west street
this is the return frontage onto union
lane so this is the union lane public
frontage this is the west street
frontage the junction of union lane
there
is that the site is a key arrival point
in the rochford town centre area action
plan sometimes people refer them to as
gateways
and therefore it requires an important
building of significant presence and
built form
the proposal has been finally revised
you'll see
in the report that it's been subject to
quite extensive revisions particularly
following the concerns expressed earlier
by the county council's specialist
advisors on listed buildings and urban
design and you'll see characteristic of
rochford and that was employed on the
roach close development some years ago
one of the features of rochford town is
the assemblage of different built
elements but like you might say built as
a lego set where you add on yeah you get
smaller sort of cottage-like elements
and other buildings and then they seem
to have neighbouring buildings and you
can see an element of this here and it's
been replicated to some extent on this
on the sandra's building but members
familiar with rochford will note that
point that it's like several blocks put
together
and the architect has picked up on that
local distinctive theme and although
this is a new building before you
given all the texturing materials and
the roof different roofing materials and
the designs
to us it looks like
a collection of buildings put together
which is very very rochford
as i say it has a good design recognized
in the local context
and the settings that are required the
building next door is a listed building
and there are a number of listed
buildings elsewhere in the town
the palette of materials is textured
render
black feather edge weather boarding
brick work timber sash windows clay
paint tiles to the roof and slate to
other elements of the roof
it does include false chimneys and some
members familiar with the previous
appeal decision remember that the
inspector in one of the dismissed
appeals took issue with the false
chimneys as not being architecturally
necessary
but this architect has gone back to them
and you'll notice that the roach close
development where the supermarket used
to be that also includes false chimneys
and whilst in this room we will know
they're false
i think when you appreciate the design
to us i think they're worth having even
though very few people will realize they
don't they don't work they're just just
cosmetic so as put together and subject
to final control over the
uh details of the materials
officers are
quite content with the design
now you'll see from the other elevations
here this is the back end into the
courtyard you'll see in a moment the
car parking areas but this is the
reverse of the building
um that you'll see actually i think i
said earlier it was three stories with
rooms in the roof but which would make
it four but you'll see this is four
stories
one of the um
legacy of this is this application
started with some four-story elements
i've been revised down you'll see it's
been with us sometime so there's been
various revisions so it's now three
stories mostly two but with rooms in the
roof elements to some of the pieces that
you'll see
it works out at what you might think is
quite a high density 169 units per
hectare but if you think of when you get
a subdivision of a garden and one
bungalow say put in it when you're only
measuring the site that
density per hectare is quite high so yes
it's a high dense scheme but you'd
expect that in a town centre
densities really work when you're
dealing with bigger sites say like 30
acre fields bit like we had in hall road
when you really need to wrestle with the
density more one of the key tests is if
it meets the standards that you have
um then the density has got to be right
so it would see re achieve full
compliance with the national technical
standards for rooms and growth size
officers consider there is a healthy
dwelling mix of one and two bedroom
flats which meets the demand in your
housing needs
you'll see that on affordable housing
there is no affordable housing in this
scheme and rather interestingly the
applicant
put forward a viability assessment which
they're required to demonstrate why they
can't provide affordable housing and we
go to the district valuer and arm of the
civil service and they have a private
commercial arm that do these assessments
and you'll see from the report that they
use two different models the
applicant used one model and came out
that he didn't need affordable housing
the district valuer used a different
model and actually
that worked out more in the applicant's
favor
so it's quite clear that by the time
you've had the construction costs by the
time you've dealt with the
decontamination of the site given the
history it isn't viable if the site then
includes affordable housing and
hopefully that's made clear in the
report
there's an element of concern i think
that would be a loss of a community
facility because of the existing garage
and business that's run on the site
which has been quite popular the policy
you have arguably looks to make sure
that things like public halls and public
spaces are not lost
what is on the site at present is a
private business it might be well
patronized but it is a private business
that operates from there from the site
if we can jump to the plan five please
you'll be able to see here in a moment
the
that's it there we go thank you
floor plans you'll see that the access
comes in where the car wash um used to
be
and adjoining the listed building which
is on this corner it also achieves a
nice gap between built form which is
two-story to that listed building again
it was a feature and a previous appeal
where the inspector dismissed the appeal
look for development on the whole site
but mainly because of the impact upon
the windows to the flat above here in
the listed building so this design
respects that you'll see in the report
there was an earlier scheme with more
flats that
came in off union lane
that's why there's references to that
and talking you through all that down to
the scheme you now have before you which
included three
units including this one here but in the
revisions the applicant dropped one of
the commercial units made that flats and
leaves the two units commercially
proposed in this part the access comes
in to the rear here
and you'll see that there's some
undercroft parking in this park a lot of
the game like they've got at roach fort
house in roach coast where you park
underneath so at the upper floor level
you've got the projection of the flats
but the ground floor you'd be able to
park underneath so this is if you like
on piers and supports to cover the
car parking underneath
um
on terms of car parking though the
starting point for this number of flats
elsewhere in the district would come out
to 58 spaces sorry 54 54 spaces
including eight visitor spaces
the council's standard allows for a
reduction in parking provision where
like this you're in a town centre where
you're close to shops and services
you've got a main line railway station
within a very short walk you've got
regular bus services the argument being
that a scheme like this centrally
located reduces dependency on the car
so for 29 flats here you have 21 car
parking spaces including one disabled
space so it doesn't work out at one
space per every flat
but you'll see that the county councils
highways technicians have had a look at
this application they've studied
information submitted by the applicant
and they agree
that in this case
the amount of provision provided is
acceptable
in terms of amenity space members will
note that there isn't much provision
there's a couple of smaller patio areas
to these two ground floor flats but
you'll again be aware that your standard
says where the site adjoins that's maybe
a key point was to adjoining but where
it joins an area of open space that can
again be relaxed now in this case across
the crossing just here and over the road
is the
joining the freight house rockford
reservoir public open space well
landscaped large area attractive area
offices consider that in this case that
close proximity offsets the need for
individual garden spaces
with the exception of those two provided
so
in a nutshell
matter of developing the site getting
rid of an unsightly building enhancing
the conservation area by the design
overcomes those failings and the
recommendation is approval subject to
the conditions set out in the report
you
there are no public speakers for this
item wall council as a councillor james
gooding council mike scepter and
councillor williams
um
so i'm going to ask councillor williams
sorry uh councillor hope you've got the
same thing councillor woodson
thank you councillor williams being the
world council
yeah thank you chairman um this site's
well known to me it's been in a an
untidy state for many years now
um and i i do actually i will support
this application thank you
thank you
thank you chairman um i i absolutely
agree that this is what uh mr strength
described as a as a gateway site um i
just wonder if you just clarify a couple
of things to me um and that is the
classification of the
retail that is on the site and then just
to confirm the protection that we have
in the retention of the retail should an
alternative application be put forward
please thank you
thank you chairman um i'm assuming
you're i'm not being asked about the
proposed retail units as opposed to the
workshops that are yeah yeah yeah
um
it's interesting because in days gone by
retail and restaurants were in different
what we call use classes a bit like
football leagues when you change from
one use into another you would need
planning permission it would become
before this committee probably or in the
weekly list
and you have policies about safeguarding
the various frontages in the town
more recently the government has
amalgamated the town centre use classes
into one
if you like created a super league and
with the exceptions of pubs
and takeaways
restaurants and retail are now in one
general class e
so
we would have to have a good reason to
say
we wish to retain the building as uh
retail use it might be the desire and
the policies you have are somewhat out
of date in context of the use classes
order
because the amendment i think was only
in 20 2020 possibly this year but
we can't
we haven't got the discretion of
refusing permission for non-retail uses
that we used to enjoy
so that's why i think the applicant has
presented the application as they have
saying it's going to be restaurant or
retail use
because then they can go to the market
and see who will take it
now we live in times where sort of
retail is on its knees
so i think we're fortunate to see here
that the applicant has put in commercial
space into the
ground floor and on a prominent corner
to continue that frontage and footfall
down to
sainsbury's the i think the economic
development team quite excited about
that feature hence their support
but if i'm being asked
how we can make sure it stays retail and
doesn't become
restaurant or some other use in class e
we don't have that control that we used
to have and i think if you was
if it made a difference to you that
between approving and refusing this you
were wanting retail
and therefore you felt rather infusing
we could impose a condition
um i would say that condition may be
maybe challengeable but
it's in the gift of this committee
thank you thank you i have one question
and then it will be councillor foster
council and then council stanley
is there to be any charging points on
the side because we're all trying to go
green eco et cetera
chairman there is a condition i think in
the recommendation that asks divisions
thank you chairman um i do have a
concern about the parking
uh i do understand
reducing the average per um flat
but going down to 21 compared with 29
flats
and i understand all the push for
alternative means of transportation but
it strikes me that's going to be a
source of some tension
and i wonder whether
eight of those flats for example would
be sold with
the condition that there's no parking
provided
thank you
council stanley
please you all i'm sorry i do have to
remind members we've all got
five minutes and sonia is timing us
thank you
thank you chairman um
three questions
or near enough three it might be four
um
on the parking
how many parking spaces does the
three-bedroomed flat
have
also i'm particularly worried that
we have planning policies
in this council
and although the inspectors are happy
with the arrangements that has been made
by the
uh officers
for the council
it seems as though our
our
rules if not rules but our
propositions that we put together
are really now in jeopardy for
developments in the future
whereas there is no amenity space
and the emergency space which is across
the road
which
uh the inspector says they can use
unfortunately there is there's a great
big global water over the other side the
road so they can't use that water
basically
so the the area
being covered for sitting
or playing
isn't as much as that is proposed
also
i'm concerned that we haven't got any
um
arrangements for low-cost
living
um
just because the site has to be
uh
some of the soil or whatever it is
contamination whatever you like to call
it that's down to the developer if he
wants to build there that's fine that
doesn't come into the restrictions of
how much
why we haven't got
this
availability
so i really do think that this is
it's a nice development i'm not saying
it isn't nice
but
the parking we've got parking standards
we also i can't see any reason why
because it's over i think it's over 15
units isn't it that they have to provide
this standard that we've that we want
i don't know if that's true but i
believe it is
um
so why aren't we why aren't we upholding
our policies as much as what we should
do thank you very much
thank you chairman um firstly i'm not an
inspector yet
it's um
planning offices but i take i take the
point um
you ask firstly how
many parking spaces a three-bedroom flat
would require the answer is 2.25
two for the number of bed spaces for the
occupiers 0.25 a quarter of a space
for visitors and in a scheme like this
the quarters increment up into complete
spaces and you round up to the
to the highest point
that is
the standard that you start with but
what your policy also says
that it may be reduced as you get closer
to the
services and things therefore the idea
being by the county council who
produce the
standards in conjunction with input from
district councils and specialists as
well
that you reduce the need of dependence
in the car so let's say if this scheme
was on faunus island somewhere where you
barely see a bus
you'd probably be insistent on
the 50 odd spaces that this would
require
but if you put this in say rayleigh town
centre or rochford town centre
you would be looking to say well do we
need all those spaces and your standard
says you can you can push those down
now in dealing with the planning
application we consult essex county
highways
and although i think this this committee
is perhaps tired of finding the county
do not object what actually happens is
the architects before the council sees
it
they go and approach the county council
because what the last thing they want to
do is for the county council to object
to not only waste their time but
lead to the whole thing in favor so they
go and do their research and find out
what may be accepted now i don't know if
in this case
they did that but it's quite common
practice for
developers to look at the car parking
they need and that
technically would be accepted
so as as planning officers we've asked
the county council for review we've
consulted them and they've said the
provision of the 21 spaces including one
disabled is good enough
for members of this committee to approve
the application
so
you have a policy that says a certain
number
but that policy also says that can be
reduced in central locations like this
and that's why the recommendation on
parking
is the way it is in terms of amenity
space there's a similar argument that in
town centre locations you've got access
yes there's a lovely waterscape there
and i get it that you can't play games
as it were but you get the amenity of
that waterscape there's the animals the
wildlife pleasure of walking alongside
water there's quite a large open space
there and where they would have done dug
the second reservoir if steam had
continued there is a flat
grassed area that gives opportunity to
sit
to play
or whatever so officers are saying yes
in the perfect world you might have
community space you can have balconies
and things like this to achieve that but
this site is right close if somebody
needs to get out get some fresh air go
for a walk they're literally
a couple of minutes away from
quite a large attractive open space and
that again like with the car parking
brings the standard down
and finally on affordable housing um
members are right that
rochford's policy says for 15 or more
you need to be looking for 35
the government actually says for schemes
of 10 or more
you need to provide uh whatever's agreed
uh um i think it's one one unit or
whatever so between 10 and 15 you you'd
get one but it's subject to a viability
test unlike the highways authority that
sometimes say we need this much money
for roundabouts or
junction improvements and things like
that it's a costed project
the government has said that the
affordable housing provision can be
subject to viability
so that if a developer has a site and
it's going to cost a lot of money
to just get started
then if
the profits of that development are
going to be eaten into by 35 affordable
housing
it ceases to be a project that they
would build they wouldn't get a
satisfactory return of probably more
than 17 interest back on what they're
paying out so it becomes unviable it's
not worth them doing
and in this case the applicant has
done an assessment what we call a
viability assessment and his consultants
used a certain model
and what we need to do and we've done is
then have that tested by if you like our
consultants and we're quite happy and
comfortable using the district valuer
they have a commercial arm as i
explained
now on this occasion the district valuer
uses a different model to what the
applicants have
and the district valuer has found it's
even more unviable than the applicant
thought it was by their testing
so you've got
double proof that on this occasion
given the contamination on the site and
the construction complexities et cetera
that the sums just don't add up if they
then got to
provide 35 affordable housing it's not
viable and the government says that
where these schemes have that
lack of viability you can dispense with
affordable housing professionally as
officers we're not happy about that
because i think we all know in this room
the need for affordable housing but
the government's rules are that if the
viability assessment is proven that they
cannot sustain the contribution of
affordable housing
then as a council we can grant
permission without that and that i think
is set out in some detail in the report
as to why on this occasion no affordable
housing can be provided
i think that's the three questions
chairman
okay
i've got um have you got a quick can i
just go through them all uh can't sell
mrs mason first then council fd
we've got club
everyone's coming man
thank you
can you hear me we can i could never
tell if these are not
right i'm going to come back slightly on
the amenity space
but from a rather different perspective
i i accept the officers comments about
the amenities space
nearby because i know the area
but an amenity space is not just
play space and recreation space
it's also used in a more practical sense
and i have some experience of rented
accommodation and the potential issues
arise that arise
when an outside drying area is not
provided
the tendency then is for
washing to be dried
indoors which often creates a mold damp
issue or alternatively for someone to
use a tumble dryer which is
expensive and obviously
um
not very carbon friendly should we say
as we can agree so i just wondered i
noticed there's a very small amenity
space there if it would be possible to
add a condition on um that there's an
outside washing line provided
would that be possible and would it be
acceptable to other members
thank you chairman i'm just checking
with the author of the report who's more
familiar than this
the problem would be about ensuring
joint access because the the area
to the the back of the the site
is is communal i think we're talking
here they've been stuck they've been
stories in here and the cycle racks are
here so logically it'll probably be
somewhere about here
if it makes a difference to members then
we could put a condition on
but i think it goes back to the idea
that i accept some people are perhaps to
some extent force somewhat forced by
price to live in certain areas and they
can't get everything that they want but
when people are looking to either take
these if they're for rent or to buy them
they would know what they're buying in
terms of there isn't this there isn't
that perhaps in the case of some flats
there isn't a parking space that might
suit some people's uh standard living
they may have dispensed with the car
they may not be drivers
um same as people with high uh washing
uh young family or perhaps a baby in the
household
would they purchase this if they're not
satisfied with the drying area but if
members are
uh if it makes a difference to members
that
there's an essential need for some form
of communal drying area
there may be some limited scope in this
area here would you say oh well
somewhere about there a bit of open
space
you could put in condition which is what
i was speaking to but the problem is the
debate we're having amongst ourselves if
you forgive us is you know just where
would it go they've got a car park there
you've got fumes of cars and things like
this
um
you know would it be the sort of thing
that they might put in to meet the
condition but then nobody ever used
because of its location you know there's
surely that would be downtown
um
i'd like to support councillor mason on
this one we've we've discussed washing
lines on
previous occasions
and although i won't
claim to be any expert on washing myself
i think in the world we're in
every little touch we can do towards a
bit of carbon neutrality and avoid the
the need for energy use on tumble dryers
is a uh is a positive step forward this
is a relatively small thing and i'm i'm
quite sure that you'll be able to work
with the applicant to come up with some
satisfactory simple
um but usable solution for for this
application so um if councillor mason
would like to just move that as a small
amendment yes as an additional condition
i would be happy to support that
thank you councillor smith yes i'd be
more than happy to it's not just the
carbon neutral it's also i've seen the
the mold and damp that can be created in
problems and i think anything we can do
to prevent that because it's a health
issue
we we should be doing and it shouldn't
be impossible to achieve so i'd like to
move with the committee's agreement that
a condition is added that outdoor
washing
dry soy washing drying facilities
is are provided and it's up to the
applicant i think to
ascertain where and how i'll second that
question
as members is everyone in agreement that
we they
have a condition on there for a washing
line please
thank you chairman um
a talking agreement on this
decliner has discussed the contamination
the parking
the social
social aspect of this
um this is a gateway into rochford and
the way it is at the moment it's a right
mess
and
i feel that i add my support to this
application
thank you uh councillor stanley
and then councillor williams and i think
we've had a good discussion
so thank you chairman uh just getting
back to the uh
principles
and the policies that we have already
got will this become
um
uh
again will this become what the
planners of sobriety said
in the way of
bringing down the
parking and also the
non-affordable housing because we do
need affordable housing
and i feel that
because even though the site is probably
contaminated and what have you
this there's there must be room for one
or two
units to be affordable if if we if we do
not have affordable housing we will
never get affordable housing on these on
these restrictions that we're putting
together i think you've had
been asked and answered i think i say
council stanley i
is it going to be a principal thing in
future in future uh development
president president sorry
we've already had the contract
thank you chairman yeah members actually
use the word precedent which is what it
is and the members are right that
examples of development can act as a um
serving to say you know an approval here
where there's not the full compliance
with car parking in rochefort town
centre you've actually got a number of
schemes where there's been flats
converted and no parking provided or
less than on the weekly list yesterday
cleared one for the site of the
former new ship yeah
and there is let there is not full
compliance on i think it was the white
horse scheme that was demolished so uh
and you've probably recalled some in
raleigh where parking has been provided
but not fully to your standard as a
remote area the thing to think of is
concentric rings if it's out in the
rural areas you need all the car parking
as you get closer to the center
then you could need possibly none at all
but i know members are not totally
comfort with that
on the affordable housing that's not the
case
on the affordable housing
you get these viability assessments that
look at the economies of the
site and the development being proposed
and they do the maths and say will this
work yeah so um
it's not a precedent as much that the
uh
this is a case where the affordable
housing is waved it can happen on any
site anywhere depending on
the circumstances
it's just the way the sums and the
economics of it all have worked out for
this scheme
yeah
hopefully that helps you but the last
question i'll take next i think we've
had a very good debate on this is
councillor williams and then we'll go to
a vote thank you not a question um
i know the area very well i've lived in
rochester for many years
this site is in desperate need of
improvement it really is in the awful
state
um most of the houses around this area
don't have
um open spaces there are many flats up
back lane up west street that are just
um just accommodation with very little
so that
is a little concern considering that
we have
um our own reservoir the open space
right opposite almost immediately
obviously within a couple of minutes
walking as the officer said um there are
three car parks large car parks within
two minutes walk
we have our own car park back lane our
own car park which is the freight house
and also the british rail car park all
within
i would say a maximum of two minutes
walk
in any other place i would be really
concerned regarding the parking issues
but where this one is i certainly
wouldn't
and chairman thank you i would like to
propose that this is recommended with
mrs mason's council of mrs mason's
amendment to the
proposal
thank you have we got a second for this
please oh we've got
council of butcher there you go
okay members can we please vote um put
your hand up and keep it up until
sonya's
said
put it down and this is to vote to
accept
with the condition from councillor mrs
mason
members for acceptance
it's unanimous thank you very much
members
and you can take your hands down there
you go
councillor mrs mason have you had time
to read the addendum please
thank you very much
all right item seven members is for
south landbridge and if i can find the
uh southampton
ginger item seven southbound ridge hall
bridge road south from
south banbridge
we've already added and again it's uh
mike's ranks to present the office's
report thank you
thank you chairman um
there is some difficulty with this one
in as much the plans we have might not
quite fit the screen so i'd ask members
to bear with us because this is a big
sight
it's of some 164 acres or 66 or more
hectares
of land spread over five fields at south
fanbridge hall here we have the
fanbridge road leading down to the
settlement from the river off off the
map here and there's the farmhouse and
buildings
in this point and it concerns the fields
primarily to the east of that site the
river crouch is up here roughly on this
scale but it also includes a parcel of
land
on the western side of the road which
will come
self-explanatory in a moment the
proposal as you see is for a solar farm
and
uh with all the screens and panels laid
out here and for a battery storage
facility and transformer
beside the beside the road there with
ease of access
there's also just off the screen and i
think we'll see a better plan later but
there's an existing solar farm that's
approved i think in 2014
which is here and you'll see members
familiar with that you see the
comparison between that one which about
that size on the scale compared to this
which is about five times larger than
before you tonight
the site would be contained within
security fencing but with mammal access
points and sort of like depressions
under them in parts of badges and the
like
can freely move about the site if we
could jump to plan two
please this shows you two arrangements
they're um located on a frame and for
the most part of the site the i think
the height is 2.3 or 2.6
2.6 thank you
but there's an area of flood uh risk
which you'll see on the final plan i
show you where because of the flood risk
they're made slightly higher i think is
it 3.2 yeah yeah
so
to combat the flooding concern they just
lifted slightly
out of that out of that tidal
level
underneath the panels that you saw would
be sewn wildflower meadow and that would
allow sheep to grow so that the farmer
could graze stock and get something to
come from that it helped keep the site
in a semi-natural state
and it would give him obviously the
return from the livestock as well as
what they get from this if we can jump
to plan three please this is the battery
storage layout alongside
we're going to have to perhaps shrink it
down if you can a bit katie thank you
the battery storage area here this is
enlarged to this small area here
and then the transformer that's
necessary to do that
their batteries are contained in
containers
and obviously
some of the electricity if we can see
planned for
that gives you just a shot of a typical
container that members are probably
quite familiar with just a a utilitarian
box
um but it's how these things work stored
and are best kept and then if we've got
plan five please which is the compound
elevation
um
to some people like me it's quite
exciting but to others it's not the best
thing etcetera but it's what it is it
looks the way it does because of the
function that it performs
so
it has a functional appearance and it's
only a part of the greater use but an
essential part so that the power is
transferred into the battery storages as
you've seen more recently at other
committees the battery storage is a way
of
um
capturing the surplus energy that's
created through the panels because
obviously the panels would be working
hardest when it's sunny and not so good
when
they're poor weather
but it allows them capacity otherwise
the
the storage would be would be lost
so increasingly more common to see
battery storage facilities alongside
this so that the energy that's been
captured
can be used when the demand is at peak
if we can lastly look at plan six please
this is the flood risk area i was
talking to you about you'll see that it
sort of seeps into as it were the layout
of the
um
of the panels which are all this sort of
like series of lines but it's in these
darker shaded areas is where the panels
would be that little bit higher just to
keep them out the predicted flood zone
should the sea wall breach or over top
members will know that the site is
within the green belt and ordinarily
this type of thing would not be
appropriate development
but the general thrust of national
planning policy however strongly favors
the provision of renewable energy
and members will see that the harm to
the greenbelt
would in offices view be outweighed by
the benefits of renewable energy and as
in this case as you've heard before more
recently this area is good access to the
national grid network
so the applicants in looking for a site
have not been able to find somewhere
with that access that's not in the green
belt
so officers feel that the
visual impact that will occur
the applicants are
looking to strengthen
some of the hedgerows and the planting
around the edges to provide screening
from the outside obviously so that it
doesn't damage the performance of the
panels but that in turn also gives you
ecological benefits and members will be
aware that it's not so much patches of
ecological
planting it's corridors which give
wildlife the opportunity to move around
and meet other members of the species
etc as well as pollination and
everything else and the enhancement of
the hedgerows and the field boundaries
by the planting would help screen this
but would also enhance the ecology
and then there's the added advantage of
the sea wall up here
it gives some screening uh through the
high high level banking to users of the
river so when you're sailing on the
crouch it'll be less easy to see because
of the
because of the sea wall but inside the
sea wall then you've got the benefit of
the the extra planting as well
the site is also on grade 3b
which is a poor agricultural land high
concentration of clay which makes it
poorly draining and a sticky uh texture
and gives only moderate yields for
cereals obviously rape winter beans or
grassland
so this is not prime agricultural land
yes it's been arably farmed but to make
a living from it in arable terms it's a
struggle
so
you won't be losing with this prime
agricultural land you'll see that they
say a life expectancy of some 45 years
with these things
and because of the nature you saw that
they sit on the land but there is
underground cabling it's quite
not too much trouble to remove the
apparatus and then remove the cabling
with some hope of returning it back to
agriculture so
it is somewhat reversible
members will see on the addendum there's
quite a number of matters firstly
there's an amendment to the great
crested new condition since penning the
report
the applicant has been able to provide
survey data which identifies uh two of
the ponds on the site uh could have the
potential for great crested loops so
you'll see there's a there's a revised
condition seven
um that covers that
and then you'll see that we've been able
to get a final response from the lead
local flood authority
that suggests the removal of condition
17
but the substitute with a new condition
17 on surface water drainage provision
and then i think it's three extra
uh conditions that the flood authorities
seek
um which you've seen on on the report
but one to minimize the off-site
flooding
the other maintenance plan for the
drainage system and then the completion
of yearly logs so that we can see that
maintenance has been carried out i think
members have been familiar with that
approach by the lead flood authority
before so the recommendation chairman is
approval
subject to the conditions set out in the
report but as amended by those
conditions on the addendum thank you
thank you very much the world
councillors
[Applause]
we have a public speaker planning agent
mr kenny dylan
and you have five minutes and i'll i'll
tell you when you've got a minute left
thank you
many thanks councillors for allowing me
the time to present to you the benefits
of our proposal my name is kenny dillon
and i am the the director of the
planning and landscape team at rsk adas
i have over 21 years experience in
planning across both local government
and the private sector the applicants
are bsr british solar renewables who
have been in the renewable energy sector
for the last 15 plus years
the proposed development is for the
construction of a forty nine point nine
nine megawatt cylip array for the 20
megawatt battery at southambridge the
land of which the proposal will be built
upon is low quality agricultural land
and the submitted agricultural land
report has found in thai site to be
grade 3b which is not considered the
best or most versatile agricultural land
the development will provide power to at
least twelve and a half thousand homes
and will provide a saving of at least
eleven thousand and seventy two tons of
co2 per year which is a substantial
reduction when you consider that the
life of the development is in the region
of 45 years
the proposed development represents an
exciting project which will make a
significant contribution to promoting
renewable energy use and moving to a low
carbon economy in support of national
and local planning policy and all other
material considerations
the site of the solar development was
chosen due to its open nature and land
area and availability of a good
connection and the lack of any
constraints and a willing and a willing
landowner
the site is in the green belt however we
have not been able to find any large
brownfield sites within the district of
the near proximity of a viable grid
connection to take the generation output
of the proposal
we have submitted a very special
circumstances case to the council and
this outlines the significant benefits
of the proposal we have worked with the
council to ensure that the site can also
deliver a biodiversity net gain of over
58
which is a significant betterment than
the current state of the site
this proposal will also result in the
planting additional hedgerow and
boundary planting to create new habitats
and green corridors for wildlife as well
as to ensure the site screen from from
from distant and local views
the site however is already well
screened given the proximity to the
flood of the northern aspect of the site
and the natural bowl in which the
majority of the site sits within
some main points of saitart is that the
development will contribute towards a
secure energy supply in the in the uk
while slowing down the negative impact
of climate change solar farms such as
this development present an ideal
solution given the low maintenance cost
and solid operation for this
once operational the site will encounter
low levels of traffic with one or two
visits per week for regular maintenance
and inspection purposes only therefore
there will be no long-term operation
changes occurring as a result of the
development the proposal will provide
long and short-term job opportunities in
the local area making efficient use of
underutilized area of agricultural land
and will support the diversification of
existing agriculture business the
proposed development will also have a
positive impact on the environment
through the provisional biodiverse net
keynesian site
and renewable energy such as this
scheme such as this will help in
tackling climate change and the social
issues that this causes to
the proposed development will lead to
ensuring secure supply of clean power
into the local and regional electricity
grids to ensure that there is power for
people to heat their homes and
businesses to run their machinery and
computers the proposed development is a
type of development which our prime
minister and the wider political
landscape support it will ensure that we
as a nation are contributing to reducing
greenhouse gas emissions and becoming a
country which can aim to be self-reliant
in in electricity generation
we fully agree in support to work for
the council during the construction of
the site and we consider that this
scheme will be a landmark scheme and an
excellent example of the best type of
solar pv development in the region and
that the council should be very proud of
this development
to recap there are no objections from
many security councils no objection from
the parish council and no significant
objection from local community i
respectfully request that you please
sorry you have one minute
thank you
i respectfully request that you please
support this development and be proud in
delivering an important and significant
renewable energy generation scheme for
your district and region i thank you
sincerely for your time
thank you thank you very much thank you
chair
visiting members
will counsel who we have here tonight is
kant's uh
councillor constable
would you like to speak
i'll get you a microphone just not if
you do
oh well please
uh councillor williams
and then councillor smith and councillor
yeah thank you chairman um just a couple
of questions right i presume that these
are fixed panels and not
the type that follow the sun
i presume um i understand that there are
there is already some
solar panels in this area can could the
officer
point out roughly where they are at the
moment please
just there thank you very much thank you
thank you
council smith uh thank you chairman um
we've got a very comprehensive report in
front of us tonight tonight
and i i think it very clearly sets out
very special circumstances which would
allow this development to take place
in the green belt
i think that it is highly appropriate
for the district and although we
obviously are working on planning uh
conditions i think that this application
does help us fulfill some of our
ambitions as a council
we are very well protected by quite a
wide range of conditions as set out in
the report and in the addendum and i
would actually be very happy straight
away to move this uh this application
for approval subject to the
recommendations as printed on the report
and in the addendum thank you
have you got a senator
foster thank you
members
we've now had the motion
sorry because i uh can you speak to the
motion get mr council mr mason please
yes sir
oh you need a mic
i think i've got one
is it on i have no idea
yes i'd like a little bit of
clarification
um i said this is a very good scheme but
there's two points that i'd like the
officers to
clarify before
i
make my mind up definitely one i haven't
seen the battery store if you could um
point that out again
i'm not sure if i've missed it in the
report but is there any screening of the
containers or any screening of the
factory store bearing in mind it's very
visible
location
inland
and the second
question i have is on page 7.9
it says solar farms are normally
temporary structures and planning
conditions can be used to ensure that
these installations are removed when no
longer in use
and the land is restored to its previous
use which i understand
um
and on page 7 11 again it says 45 years
my recollection
last time when i heard a similar
application it was the life of the solar
panels was 25 years
so
i don't know if technology has improved
but i am concerned about the disposal at
the end of the site and i don't know if
that's covered in the conditions i have
looked but forgive me if i've missed it
perhaps the officers could clarify those
two areas
if you could bear with us chairman we're
just looking for that condition we think
it's there but we're trying to take
members to it
once i could answer 7.3 there is um
the protection of
tree protection barriers identified
for the containers et cetera
well while uh councilman can i ask
cancer stanley please
thank you chairman um two things
i've got concerns about um
the water runoff from the solar panels
is a very very big area and the runoff
from the solar panels
um how is that being contained are there
uh attenuation tanks or something like
that because obviously if you've got the
ground covered
which you have the water can't get it
penetrate into the ground it's going to
run off
from one to the other and and so on very
very quickly also
the
battery container store has that got an
intent an attenuation tank or some sort
of uh
means of collecting the water from that
area
thank you chairman um
there's no direct condition about
screening of the
uh
battery storage facility but there is a
general
landscaping condition that requires and
it's got that purpose about screening we
could extend that to
cover
the the
battery storage facility in that area
so
that's
that part
condition 10 of the recommendation
deals with the decommissioning
i can't help you with the life
expectancy of the screens i don't know
if the panels can be replaced and sat on
the same frames or whether as members
suggested the technology has improved
but the applicant has given and you
heard him say
are 45 years so so that's the content of
the application and you've had that
doubled up by the applicant
in terms of the runoff
there's a condition in the addendum that
deals with the surface water
management
and i would hope that that details for
that condition uh four of sorry um
17 a revised 17
which i think you'll see was a was a
residential housing scheme one which is
why it's been changed um
condition 17 will deal with the the
runoff for those areas and again we
could extend that to the battery storage
facility so i think that condition 17
has revised on the addendum uh would
seek to address that issue raised thank
you
thank you
right members we've had um could i just
come back madame chairman
okay could i just ask if councillor
smith would be happy to
have that those tell us the way mrs
mason can you bring the mic closer
because you're quite softly spoken sorry
can i just ask council steve smith if
he'd be happy for the those two
um
conditions to be extended to the battery
store the screening
and i think
and the water run up the two that the
officer said could be extended is he
happy for those to be extended um
the way i've i've read the
report myself i i felt that the
the screening
that is described
was about all the various elements of
the cycle if it helps to just
specifically mention the
um
the the battery storage as well and that
doesn't in any way compromise any safety
issues regarding that then quite happy
for that to go in
but i believe that the the suds
conditions
as outlined on the addendum
uh satisfactory deal with that issue
thank you
thank you members we'll go to the vote
for acceptance or a recommendation for
acceptance can i please uh have put your
hands up for acceptance please
agenda eight is the michelin farm
artillery road
and casey rogers will present the
officer's report that will be up katy
thank you chairman
so we'll show on screen um the location
plan but this is it's not an application
for planning permission israel yeah okay
um
so chairman this application relates to
a request to modify a legal agreement
the legal agreement relates to a
planning consent for commercial
development at the michelin farm site
it's a site on a screen
edged red
the legal agreement contains a
requirement the developer pay a
financial contribution to essex county
council
towards early years in child care
provision
since the determination of the
application to which the legal agreement
relates the county council no longer
seek financial contributions towards
early years in child care provision from
commercial employment development so
whilst they still do in relation to
residential schemes they do not in
relation to employment schemes
the county council are therefore minded
to agree the request to modify the legal
agreement to remove the requirement for
this contribution
and the recommendation is therefore that
this council also agree the proposed
modification thank you thank you very
much
any visiting members
either no thank you
i'll turn over
oh it would be council norman he's not
here
so um from the chair i'll move um a
motion
to agree
that we remove this uh
modification
if that's the right wording have i got a
second degree
oh sure councillor sure sorry mr shaw
members
can i uh
have a show of hands for voting in favor
of this place
it's unanimous you can uh put your hands
up thank you members for a very good um
meeting very good debates
and i closed the meeting at i'm not
quote
2033 thank you very much
and i don't see any any of you have a
goodies have a good christmas